[Música]
como un día de luto describieron cientos
de manifestantes la conmemoración del 2
de octubre en las calles de la capital
de chile indígenas mapuches se unieron a
líderes sociales en reclamo de respeto
por la diversidad cultural en el marco
de esta cuestionada fecha que recuerda
la llegada de cristóbal colón a américa
en el año 1492 y lo que en chile se
vivió como una manifestación en ecuador
se tradujo en un abierto rechazo por
parte de los grupos indígenas hermanos y
hermanas en todo el mundo organizaciones
de todo el mundo expresan que no hay
nada que celebrar
que fue un gran genocidio creo que el
genocidio más grande que se ha visto en
los pueblos indígenas de la tierra para
evitar que fuera derribada por los
manifestantes que se esperaban en el
cumplimiento de esta fecha en ciudad de
mexico la estatua de cristóbal colón fue
retirada en la nación azteca conocida
por ser una de las más críticas contra
el pasado colonial español el presidente
se refirió a la conmemoración de esta
jornada e insistió en su propuesta de
que sean ofrecidas disculpas a los
pueblos afectados para que el año
próximo
se lleven a cabo estas ceremonias
para ofrecer disculpa a los pueblos
originarios y hacer el compromiso de la
no repetición
que nunca jamás se vuelvan a cometer
atrocidades para el saqueo
no al colonialismo
no al sometimiento en la víspera
ciudadanos repudiaron la creación de
monumentos a líderes españoles no estoy
de acuerdo en tener este tipo de
monumentos en la calle porque pienso que
representan represión o en los últimos
meses incluso las protestas del
movimiento blacks life matter abordaron
el rechazo al colonialismo al motivar el
retiro de las estatuas de colom entre
otros personajes de la época